Jacksonville Florida reopened its
beaches one week ago today with some
restrictions there the mayor Lenny curry
was with us to explain his decision a
week ago he's back today and mayor thank
you for coming back and good afternoon
to you you know what not you know what
everybody was saying they were they said
over the weekend have you had any
problems mayor we haven't in fact after
the initial opening the crowds have
really thinned out people are following
the restrictions 6:00 to 11:00 in the
morning 5:00 to 8:00 at night
no sunbathing no chairs no coolers keep
moving keep walking and keep your
distance in fact I'm on the governor
descent governor DeSantis is task force
to reopen the state and that task force
is discussing potentially using the wick
Jacksonville's restrictions for its
beaches for a model around the Sun
that's interesting just back to last
week again you you you were being
criticized because it looked like in
some of the images that people were not
six feet apart what did you say to them
that we had so our beaches they each
have a mayor there's three mayor's at
the beaches and we had them at they were
out there police were out there Fire and
Rescue were out there all the feedback
that I got was people were at work were
practicing social distancing they
weren't getting into large groups so
look we just had to weather the
criticism and I expect that will
continue as cities and counties and
states reopen in their own way based on
the data they have in the judgment they
make if there will be critics if you're
not willing to accept that you're not
going to make progress any more
loosening of the rules that you
established a week ago mayor no more
loosening but I do think we're getting
closer our positive test rate is dropped
below 5% it's at 4.8% now we're
following the white house president
Trump's phases to reopen to tail Taylor
to our County President Trump and the
federal government just got us a hundred
and sixty million dollars in Kerr's
funds we're putting 40 million dollars
of that to provide rent utility and
mortgage relief 35 million to expand
testing so we are on the road to
recovery Wow steady as she goes Thank
You mayor for coming back Lenny Carrie
there in Jackson thank you sir